[Music]
[Music]
right now a scenario we would all like
to see is the fall of Putin and the
collapse of his entire regime at the end
of the day this is one of the reasons
behind the sanctions program to turn
Russian Elites against the great leader
so we are talking about a campaign of
isolation that goes far beyond trade the
goal is to get to the heart of all
Russians for example four years ago
Russia was hosting the World Cup in the
upcoming one in Qatar they are not even
allowed to participate however Putin
himself is also starting to play too
much with the emotions of his people
check this out Putin's call app fuels
Russian's anger protests and violence to
give you an idea according to Forbes
more than 700 000 Russians left the
country in just the two weeks following
the announcement of mobilization can we
trust these numbers well the truth is
that it's relatively easy to count them
you just need to add up the figures
given by the host countries of course
there might be errors but in theory it
seems reasonable to think that hundreds
of thousands of Russians are fleeing the
recruiters we have also seen all sorts
of Street protests and campaigns on the
internet think about it it's one thing
to support a war you see on TV
accompanied by the appropriate
propaganda is quite another to support a
war where you are going to be told to
fight on the front lines yourself
[Music]
and the truth is that this is not the
first time that this has happened in
Russia that's right if we look at a
little bit of History we'll see that
before Ukraine Russia has carried out
two large mobilizations one in World War
II and another one in World War One
during World War II almost all Russians
understood that they had to fight after
all they were being invaded by Germany
however the mobilization in World War
one ended really badly for the gremlin
in this case a military Mutiny broke out
a mutiny that was key to the fall of the
SARS and the rise of the Bolsheviks
that's correct in today's video we're
going to look at in detail what happened
in Russia in 1917. so the question is
what does the Russia of the tsars and
Putin's Russia have in common could the
war in Ukraine bring about regime
collapse like the one that brought about
the Revolutions of 1917. today on
visualpolitik we're going to answer all
of these questions but first obviously
we need to look at some history
[Music]
the February Revolution
no I have not made a mistake I did just
say the February Revolution and not the
October Revolution which is the one we
all know about and the fact is that
months before the Communists took
control of Russia another Revolution
took place this time a liberal
Revolution so you may be wondering what
exactly happened let's find out the
Russian Empire was going through a
period of extreme decadence at the
beginning of the 20th century the
reforms to modernize Russia and bring it
closer to other European powers had been
cut short with the assassination of Tsar
Alexander II his successor Alexander III
returned to the old formula employed by
the romanovs for three centuries a
mixture of Orthodoxy autocracy and
nationalism that is the classic idea of
saris Russia based on loyalty to the
Romanov Dynasty government traditional
religious faith and glorification of the
motherland
his son Nicholas II did even worse he
first waged a war with Japan that led to
one of Russia's greatest historical
humiliations the discontent provoked the
revolution of 1905 in which the Tsar
made some symbolic concessions such as
the creation of the Duma a parliamentary
assembly that when it came down to it
lacked real power but later in 1914 he
became the defender of Serbian
nationalism and involved Russia in the
Great War the first world war Russia
faced Germany and the austro-hungarian
empire in the war despite initial
victories over the austrians the Russian
army was crushed by Germany causing
thousands of casualties the front was
stabilized and Tsar Nicholas II left for
the front to lead his troops despite the
success of the brulasov offensive based
on half a million casualties Russia was
soon cornered again to suffer defeat
after defeat 1917 began in Russia with a
very cold weather and high inflation the
majority of workers in Saint Petersburg
or petrograd as it was known then had to
choose between freezing or trying to
keep warm at the risk of starvation
since an egg cost four times as much in
1914 and butter five times as much in
addition to food shortages and extreme
poverty 1.7 million Russians had died in
the war another 5 million were wounded
1.5 million had been taken prisoner and
just as many had deserted from the Army
the protests were continuous and more
and more numerous and no we're not
talking about the Bolshevik Revolution
we are talking about the one that took
place months before this was not a
Communist Revolution but a liberal
Revolution
in this case the Tsar tried to put down
the Revolt by force but the various
garrisons of Saint Petersburg revolted
and disobeyed the orders received a week
later Nicholas II abdicated sarism was
replaced by a provisional government
that was decided to continue Russia's
participation in the Great War while
respecting the international alliances
in which Tsar Nicholas II had involved
the country the problem with this
provisional government was that it was
very weak and the streets the petrograd
Soviet a sort of workers and soldiers
Council in what was then the Russian
Capital today Saint Petersburg was
becoming more and more powerful while
the most radical revolutionaries the
Bolsheviks were gradually growing
stronger in the petrograd Soviet the
Russian provincial government was
composed of liberal politicians moderate
socialists and socio-revolutionaries
like Alexander kreninsky who soon became
minister of War and the Navy at the head
of the army karensky played an All or
Nothing Game what did this desperate
attack to avoid defeat in the war
consist of well we're going to look at
that right now
the karensky offensive
[Music]
Russia had committed itself along with
allies to launch an offensive to divide
the attention of the German and
austro-hungarian enemy on two fronts but
the Russian army was not at its best
discipline had fallen sharply after the
abdication of the Tsar the troops didn't
trust the commanders because of the
enormous number of casualties suffered
by the Russian army in addition the
large number of casualties had two
fundamental consequences for Russia
firstly although the soldiers were still
primarily of peasant origin the latest
conscripts in 1916 had begun to include
middle-aged men secondly and more
importantly the new recruits were being
sent to the front with less training
than their predecessors so they were
cannon fodder does this sound familiar
at all exactly we're not going to say
that history is repeating itself but it
is clear that there are a number of
parallels Putin's new troops will suffer
heavily in Ukraine as they will have
basically no training UK Intel says in
1917 this lack of preparation also
affected the officers particularly in
the lower ranks the senior officers were
aware of all this and complained about
the poor ability of the new commanders
and the poorer quality of the reinforced
received but wait a moment because they
still had to deal with an even greater
problem
the new arrivals at the front were
opposed to the war and thought that the
failure of the karensky offensive would
sink the provisional government and
would serve to achieve peace more
quickly something similar to what many
Russians in Ukraine might be thinking
right now Russian propaganda has sold
the invasion of Ukraine as a military
operation to fight fascism in the
neighboring country Russians therefore
see the intervention in Ukraine as
something completely unrelated to the
day-to-day life of their own country in
the earliest 20th century Russians also
did not consider World War one as an
existential issue this is something that
the Russia of the SARS and Putin's
Russia have in common the lack of a
clear ideology in running the country it
is clear that ukrainians are struggling
to survive as a country they want to be
independent and have a democratic
political system similar to that of the
European Union but what are the Russians
fighting for unlike the Soviet era today
the Kremlin lacks such a clear ideology
as communism in other words the Soviets
wanted to spread their Revolution to
every corner of the planet putinism
however has no such International
aspirations Britain's approach is purely
nationalistic it is based on the idea
that there is nothing better in life
than being Russian the old romantic
notion of nationalism already exploited
by the tsars however in the 21st century
this is not enough motivation to compel
citizens to go to the front and even
less when you consider the conditions in
which the Kremlin sends its men anger
mounts as Russian draftees thrown into
battle without training equipment the
karensky offensive failed when Russian
soldiers mutinied and refused to
continue fighting these insubordinations
gave Germany time to reinforce its front
and launch a counter-offensive far from
bolstering the morale of the Russian
army the offensive proved that the
morale of its troops was at rock bottom
and that none of the generals could
count on the soldiers under their
command to execute the orders that they
were being given
[Music]
problems were piling up for the Russian
provisional government which by then had
been pinned down for several months
thanks to the brilliant idea the German
enemy had come up with because someone
thought let's see if Lennon wants to
negotiate peace with us why don't we
take him out of his Exile in Switzerland
and bring him to Russia and as we say
here on visualpolitik no sooner said
than done in April of 1917 a crucial
historical train journey took place
Vladimir Landon traveled from Zurich to
petrograd he traveled more than three
thousand kilometers on
1864 miles something that would have
been impossible in the midst of the
world war without German help but
Berlin's Ambitions were quickly rewarded
upon his arrival in Saint Petersburg
Lennon announced the April Theses he
promised that the Bolshevik came to
power Russia would emerge from the war
give the land to The Peasants and power
to the proletariat it was the era of the
historic slogan all power to the Soviets
that's what it is like to have access to
a mass agitator like Lenin he knew
perfectly well what the Russians wanted
to hear today the opposition to Putin
does not have a leader a role model to
unite the Russian discontent with the
war and no one seems to be supporting
the Russian opposition at least not with
the same intensity and above all with
his many rubles as the Kaisers Germany
placed in the hands of the Bolsheviks a
century ago Edward Bernstein a German
politician who is considered one of the
fathers of social democracy claimed that
the German government financed the
Bolsheviks between 1917 and 1918 with
about 10 million dollars of the time to
help them take power today Western
support is concentrating on propping up
the Ukrainian government but supporting
the Russian opposition was very
effective a century ago so how did the
Bolsheviks seize power check this out
the October Revolution
[Music]
after the failure of the offensive the
provisional government led by karensky
tried to reorganize the Army by placing
lavar cornelov in charge this General
fed up with the chaos in which Russia
was plunged tried to establish a
military dictatorship to do so he
launched a counter-revolutionary coup
d'etat karnalov failed but not because
of the opposition of karenzi's
provisional government which by this
team had really no power over anyone
because no one believed in its Authority
cornelov ran up against the Soviets and
fundamentally against the resistance of
the Bolsheviks this field coup
reinforced the loss of authority of the
officers in the eyes of the troops who
saw them as mere representatives of an
authoritarian power that had to be ended
it also meant the definitive backing of
the Bolsheviks the most radical
revolutionaries who guaranteed that
there would be no return to sarism the
Bolsheviks demanded the government grant
freedom of movement to the Red Guard we
are talking about detachments of workers
who were armed and who would be decisive
for the success of the Revolution the
Bolsheviks rallied the workers and
soldiers of petrograd to overthrow the
provisional government a new executive
was formed led by Lenin which took
control of the countryside and created
the Checker a political and Military
Intelligence organization aimed at
crushing any dissent what's more as they
had promised they signed a peace treaty
with Germany an agreement that meant an
ephemeral Independence for the Ukrainian
Republic
[Music]
the Triumph of the October Revolution
started a six-year Civil War the Red
Army and the white Army which comprise
all of the enemies of the Bolshevik
Revolution confronted each other the
conflict completely devastated the
country and culminated in the Triumph of
Soviet power possibly today the
conditions do not exist for a revolution
to overthrow Putin in other words who is
now the main leader of the anti-putin
opposition Alexi navalny unlike Lennon
in his day Nevada is not an exile but in
Russian jail so it seems to be somewhat
difficult to support him from the West
even so navali's allies continue to move
this message was launched in early
October by Ivan's danov navalny's
right-hand man who is currently in
Exiles
the problem for revolutions is that
things have changed a lot since Lennon's
time the control over Society over the
communications of dissonance is much
greater than it was possible to have a
century ago and another of Putin's
advantages is that he is not so worn out
in the eyes of the Russian population
fundamentally because of the regime's
propaganda which does not try to
convince Russians that the world needs
Putin in the same way that for example
chavism extolled Hugo Chavez is very
different Putin's popularity has always
rested on the apathy of the people
something similar to what happened
during the tsarist era Russians have
long understood that politics is Putin's
in his friend's business however as the
war in Ukraine is far from going as the
Kremlin expected the discontent is
producing movements that months ago were
completely unexpected which ones let's
take a look right now
[Music]
put inoffensive
Kremlin has doubled its bet with the
partial mobilization and as you can
imagine this does not come for free as
everyone understands except from Chechen
kradov going to the front Lanes is not
any fun in general especially without
adequate preparation what's more by the
time the draft was announced seven
months of War had already passed more
than half a year in which many had seen
how their compatriots returned wounded
or even dead so some have dared to raise
their voices against how the
mobilization is being carried out this
is the case of the president of the
Republic of Dagestan the Republic of
Dagestan is a Russian region bordering
Georgia and Azerbaijan on the banks of
the Caspian Sea well the governor of
this region is the man you see on the
screen Sergey milkov Sergey milikov is
no Putin Enemy by any stretch of the
imagination he has a high-flying
military career he has risen into a high
rank in the National Guard he is now the
highest Authority in this region of
Russia however look at what he has said
about the recruiting officers of the
Armed Forces
foreign
that many of those thousands of young
people will not return and leave his
Republic even older but wait a minute
because dissatisfaction with how
Russia's partial mobilization has been
organized goes far beyond an anecdotal
problem in Dagestan
it is an established Trend Russia's
poorest and most marginalized regions
are the ones that are risking the most
in Ukraine Russia's ethnic minorities
lament the war in Ukraine there are big
unknowns about Russian casualties
because you know that in Wars
transparency is the first casualty but
there is research that clearly indicates
that soldiers from the poorest regions
of the Federation such as on the border
with Mongolia and Dagestan itself are
disproportionately represented among
Russian casualties similarly very few
young men from the country's major
capitals are dying in the war
undoubtedly a smart move on Putin's part
because maintaining the Loyalty of the
elites will keep him in power
Revolutions in the 20th century spread
from the cities to the periphery and
never the other way around this time
there will be no petrograd Soviets but
beware of irritating the peripheral
republics so the question is do you
think that at some point Putin's regime
may fall or do you think that his
control over Russian Society is so great
that A revolution is completely
impossible you can leave me your answers
in the comments below and of course
don't forget that we have new videos
here on visualpolitik every week so
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss any of our updates and if you like
this video like it so we know all the
best and I'll see you next time
[Music]